I was born and I grew up in I coast and
like so many other African kids I used
to resent my blackness including my
hair I longed for straight hair that
could be easily managed and
brushed after years of using air relaxer
I went back to natural hair at 16 after
an incident with my hair that forced me
to shave and start over and it was a
very hard new
beginning but at 18 while I was still in
the process of learning how to love my
natural hair I came across a photo album
showing the air of African women in
precolonial society and I was instantly
inspired seeing that photo album was so
powerful to me it made me see air
completely differently not just as a
beauty tool but as a way to communicate
and to tell stories about who we are and
immediately I start Ed to experiment
with my own air I wanted to see what I
was able to create and today I'm an
artist and air sculpting is one of my
media I use my heart to advocate for
what I believed in particularly for
issues that affect women's and girls but
it didn't start that way at the
beginning I was just doing beautiful
shapes for the aesthetic aspect I
started with doing Simple geometrical
shapes
just for the beauty of it and when I was
posting those shapes online I was
receiving so much love that it
encouraged me to push my limit to create
more complex
sculpture from 2017 when I first started
until now I made hundred of sculpture
some can be playful other can be very
serious so here are just a few example
of what I can do with my
hair
animals
random things like an umbrella or
car
portraits text like here we I right
perfect with my hair because I do
believe my hair is
perfect
cartoon
sunflowers fashion
accessories
Wings even zodiac inspired a sty because
my raising sign is Scorpio I'm another
astrology
freaks
Medusa and even body
[Applause]
parts the process to make the sculpture
is actually pretty simple the idea come
to my head I do a little sketch and then
I just sced using my natural hair some
air extension and wire I just wrap the
bread around the wire and then it's very
easy for me to shape as I want and in
general you know to make the sculpture
being able to stand on top of my head
the base need to be extremely tight so
if you're wondering is it eful
yes yes it is but this is why in general
I quickly under it after the photo shoot
most of the time I will take the picture
by myself but when I need help my little
sister Fria who is the most supportive
person of the planet will help me and
depending of what I want to create a
sculpture can take me from 5 minutes to
more than three four five
hours when I started to create I was
just doing as I said before for the
beauty of it no meanings but it change
in 2018 when one of my photo series went
completely viral it was this one I
shaped my hair as a second pair of hands
very playful in various
configuration and I started to receive a
lot of message from black women around
the world telling me that seeing my my
heart help them to feelit better about
the hair about the Blackness and I
realized okay actually what I'm doing is
pretty powerful so maybe it can just
serve a greater purpose and I can use it
to advocate for change so I decided to
use my hair as a platform to advocate
for the equity of
sexes why this specific subject you may
ask because I was born and I grew up in
an environment that normalized the bad
treatment of women I have my experience
many women have the experience so it
touched me a lot and when it comes to
equality of sexes I touch a lot of
different subjects unfortunately I can't
share all of all of them with you I can
just give you today a glimpse of
it body autonomy and selflove is very
important for me I went myself into a
long process of toward self- L coming
from a place where I used to dislike
everything about myself to a place where
I just love everything so I love to
inspire
myself so I love to inspire myself from
our female body to create sculpture and
shapes that are associated with
uplifting world to empower those who
need it and with the sculpture what I
want to do is to encourage women to have
aeny over their body but also to destig
ize all the classic taboo around our
bodies like for example
period
aging
disabilities and much more this culture
for example
was was to address the big taboo of body
air on women when I was 15 I posted a
photograph on me on social media without
realizing that my body my amp ha was
visible and immediately the comment were
wild this is disgusting go shave ew I
can buy you a razor if you want I was
traumatized so I deleted the picture and
after that I started to shave way more
regularly even if for me it's a very
uncomfortable routine it took me years
to be able to love my body the way it is
and to embrace everything including my
body
hair beside all the topic related to
baddies I love to also address topics
related to our intellect as women
because this world not only encourage
women to dislike their body but also
encourage women to dislike what they
have inside and I think just as we're
supposed to love our bodies we're
supposed to also own our hopes dreams
our idea our opinion without shame and
for that I
[Applause]
think and for that I think education is
extremely important this is why I did
this sculpture
[Laughter]
unfortunately in iOS many women still
can't
read when I was a child many women were
working at our home as nannies they
weren't educated they would ask me to
read the text messages because they
couldn't in rural Ivory course many
parents think that is useless to put a
girl in school because they're better at
home learning how to cook how to take
care of of home for their future husband
but when it comes to their son they are
allowed to have an education so most of
the of the time those women would end up
marrying older men and when those men
abandon them they're left with nothing
with very few career options because
they're not educated and to me this is
[Music]
revolting growing up in an environment
where I wasn't always encouraged to love
who I was my journey has been about
becoming my own friend and Advocate and
when I embraced the capacity I have to
share my stories and the one of others I
find the strength to advocate for what I
believe in through my hair thank
you thank
you